I welcome you to the Holistic Health Show, Dr. Connors, and I look forward to hearing about your cancer clinic.
Now, first, you believe that looking for the cause of cancer in your patients is important.
Why is this so, and what tests do you use?
Well, thank you for having me first. I appreciate it.
So, there's always a cause to cancer. So, cancer, as you know, is one cell started a rapid replication phase,
and reproduced more cells than are in a state of rapid replication.
So, something had to get in that cell and cause that to take place, usually it's some sort of toxin or maybe a virus or fungus or something like that.
So, looking for the cause is important because if you can come close to figuring that out and try to treat that, then you're going to have a better chance of preventing cancer in the first place or preventing it spread.
So, that's an important piece for what we do. For instance, if you look at the research for stomach cancer, for say, the statistics show that I think it's 90-some percent of stomach cancers caused by H. Pylora, which is a bacteria that can reproduce strongly in the gut, can be part of our normal flora.
It's not supposed to be present in the stomach because of the stomach acid helps keep that at bay, but when we have a decreased stomach acid H. Pylora can grow like crazy in the stomach.
And once it gets into those cells that lie in the stomach, it can be, and it's the number one cause of stomach cancer worldwide, according to the World Health Organization.
So, why don't we look for causes of cancer in other places and treat that? Where with stomach cancer, they typically do treat the H. Pylora, but they tend to and I'm talking about standard medicine tends to ignore the cause of other cancers.
Do you use the cancer sensitivity test or have you used it at any time?
We don't, we have some patients that use cancer sensitivity testing before they come to us.
We use kinesiology, we use genetic testing to help to get to those pieces.
We find that those are fairly successful for us, helping narrow down our answers.
Nothing is going to be perfect, nothing's a perfect test, even our gold standard tests are perfect, but try your best to get to what you think is going to be the best for the patient.
Dr. Forsyth in Reno, who did a lot with alternative treatments, and he used the cancer sensitivity at one point, but he's backed off on it now.
He says it's not as effective as they thought it was initially.
I actually spoke to another colleague of ours that actually shared with me a couple of years ago that Dr. Forsyth actually stopped using that test because he didn't think the accuracy was up to stuff.
And Dr. Sapa at the Acadia clinic in Germany is on my cancer board, and he said that he had stopped or he'd never used it because he never thought that it was very effective.
Sure.
It's something that at the time sounded really interesting and exciting, but I guess these things change.
Part of the problem is that I think part of the problem is that what works in a person's body is different than what's going to work in a petri dish.
So you hear a Facebook or something that XYZ nutritional figures 97 kills 97% of cancer cells.
Well, if you put bleach in a petri dish with cancer, it's going to kill all the cancer cells, but you can't drink bleach.
So what works in your body doesn't always work in the test.
Well, it works with a test who doesn't always work in the body, so it's still a more complicated than that.
And what bothers me sometimes on Facebook is that they take the animal studies or the lab studies and then start saying it kills cancer.
Well, it hasn't reached the point of being tested on human jet.
It's just been tested.
Right.
You do a mouse study doesn't always equate to a human study for sure.
You mentioned kinesiology testing in your diagnosing and I thought that was interesting.
Can you tell us a bit about that?
So kinesiology tested is a four muscle testing that we do in our office.
I've been doing it for 35 years.
It isn't perfect and it certainly is dependent upon the practitioner.
So I would never defend all people who do kinesiology.
But it's an art form that leads to be mastered and some people are find themselves to be good at it and some people really struggle with it.
We've been confident.
I believe it's a gift and we've been confident that we've been successful with it.
But again, there's human error and everything.
But it could help narrow things down.
I also included, I did a book recently to make money for my cancer foundation on preventing cancer.
And I used a dreams as a diagnostic tool because in my case when I had lung cancer in 1974, I went to the doctor because I had a dream
that told me to go to the doctor and have x-rays.
And I've known other people that had dreams like this so I feel that even though it's not accepted by traditional medicine,
that there are those people that receive guidance through their dreams.
Sure.
Then how are genetics related to cancer?
Well, there's very few cancers that have specific genetic cause.
However, looking at a person's genetic pathways can really help point to helping a person gain health whether they have cancer or anything.
So there are two more suppressor genes.
Those are genes that we have in most of our cells that if a cell goes into rapid replication,
the tumor suppressor genes kick on and help kill that cell.
That's what your tumor suppressor genes are.
And people can have defects in multiple tumor suppressor genes systems and be more susceptible to getting cancer.
So some familial cancers can be because familially you have inherited defects on specific tumor suppressor genes.
Therefore your risk of certain type of cancer can go up that you inherit from your parents.
But that still isn't the cause.
We understand the definition of cancer is cell that goes into rapid replication.
A defect in a tumor suppressor gene is not going to cause a cell to go into rapid replication.
However, a defect in tumor suppressor genes can inhibit the body's normal defense of mechanism against a cell that does go into rapid replication.
So therefore it's a contributing factor to a person getting a diagnosis of cancer.
So looking at those are important.
And there are also known tumor oncogenes, which are genes that if I have defects in this gene, it can actually increase my risk of cancer.
And they're known supportive system.
So let's use the example of curcumin, the active form of turmeric.
That is multiple studies have been done on that to help interrupt oncogenes.
So if a person has defects that oncogenes that increase their risk of cancer, using an intervention like curcumin can help decrease one's risk.
But beyond the tumor suppressor genes and the tumor oncogenes, it proves us to look at other things like genes that control our detoxification pathways.
So whenever we said cancer is rapidly replicating cells, what caused that in the first place? Well, something that got inside the cell that interrupted that replication cycle at the nucleus and allowed rapid replication to take place.
Well, how could that be? Well, it can be toxins that are not getting out of my body.
So I could eat really well and try to eat organic and stay away from additives, calories, chemicals, toxicities.
Regardless, we're all, we live in this world that we're exposed to air pollutants and, you know, chemicals, you know, my shirt is not dyed with blueberries and there's carpeting on the floor and there's gasification of different chemicals that I breathe eat in.
My liver is working over, drive to try to get rid of all these toxins that I'm exposed to even if I'm trying to eat a clean light, live a clean life.
So these liver detox pathways have to be healthy. So if you look at, from a genetic standpoint, if I have defects on my say to Chrome P450 detox pathways, I'm not going to be as fast of a detoxer as somebody who doesn't have defects on those pathways.
So I think it's beneficial to look at all those genes as many as we know about at this time and see how we could possibly better support the pathways that I have issues with.
So that's what we try to do.
Then how important is nutrition in your protocol?
Nutrition is extremely important. So if you, when you look at somebody with cancer, cancer has to have a fuel source because this is rapidly replicating cells very high metabolic rate.
It needs a fuel to continue to do that, to continue to make energy to do what it needs to do to grow.
And so then you have to look at, you try to cut off that fuel source. So cancer will typically be fed, will commonly be fed through glycolysis, through breakdown of sugar.
So looking at person with a diagnosis of cancer should instantly cut way back on their sugar intake, cut back on their carbohydrates.
But also cancers can be fed through proteins, through amino acids, methionine, and glutamine, and elucid.
So looking at cutting back on animal proteins typically is what we look at too.
So what we call a mixed diet, if I don't know, how do I know my cancer is fed mainly through glycolysis or mainly through proteins?
Well, you could, you could experiment and go on a more ketogenic type diet where you're eating typically eating a little bit more protein and see how my cancer growth rate is going or vice versa.
We could go on maybe a more juicy diet. So juicy might be a little bit higher carbohydrates, but I'm going to go more vegan with my diet and see how my cancer grows.
We test for that, but if you don't know, it might be more healthy to go on a more of a mixed diet.
Stay low carb, but also semi-vegan, and that tends to be good for a lot of people as well.
And the other thing about nutrition and diet is dairy, with cancer, most of our cancer ratios we take off dairy.
Try to get them off as much dairy as possible because you think of what dairy is to make, is to help a little baby grow to be an adult.
Whether it be a 60-pound cow into a 1200-pound cow or a child into an adult, so it has a lot of factors that can stimulate growth rates.
So we don't want to feed growth factors to someone who already has a growth factor problem that is cancer.
So staying off dairy is a good idea as well.
When I had lung cancer, my doctor put me on a vegan diet and stayed on that for two years, and it took two years before I was cleared.
But I used all natural, holistic interventions, so I didn't do any chemo, radiation, or surgery.
And that was back 40, well, it would be 45 years, the 21st of this month.
Wow, congratulations.
And I never had a recurrent, so I think that what my doctor recommended spoke well of his practice.
I think in many ways he was way ahead of his practice because some of the research for what he did came out five or six years ago.
But the medical profession closed him down years after I had treatment.
And the ketogenic, I have interviewed some people that have had a lot of success with that.
And I know Dr. Esslinger in Reno, at least when I talked with him last, was using that in his treatment.
Yeah, I just caution against thinking that one only one way is the right way.
Everybody's different, your cancer might be different, so experimenting with different types of diets is the best way to go.
That's what I think too.
And Dr. Gonzalez, when he was alive, he used the two types that were direct opposites.
One was for meat eaters, the others was for the vegetarian, and that seemed to work.
And I know he said that the vegan was better for those who had lung cancer, which is what I had.
And that's what I went on.
And for breast cancer, which is what Susan Summers had, and she went on that.
So I think that the variety is probably better than saying everyone has to do a certain thing.
And also Dr. Isaacs mentioned when I talked with her, and she's followed up, she worked with, as you know, Dr. Gonzalez.
But she says that they give some additional pancreatic enzymes that allows them to be a little more flexible with the diet than it was at the time that I treated.
Yeah, I know Dr. Gonzalez and Dr. Isaacs, they do metabolic typing, which is something that you can do online too.
It's a series of, I don't know, 400 or 600 questions that you go through to help decide what type of diet that you should be on.
That's a good way to help with your decision-making process as well.
But typically, like lung cancer and colon cancers, this should be more likely that they're going to be on a more vegan type diet.
Brain cancer is going to be much more likely that a ketogenic diet is going to be better.
But doing a metabolic type diet is, or a question error can be helpful in determining that.
And I agree with Dr. Gonzalez with enzymes.
So, doing a Dr. William Kelly approach with high dose enzymes is one way to go.
But just by getting some digestive enzymes with each meal to help all your food digest better, and then to do it off meal on an empty stomach to help it help you absorb those enzymes.
So it could help eat up the light eater on the cancer.
It could be really helpful and get a European system to it.
I use the Woldymogus, but they've been either discontinued or banned or something.
They're no longer available in this country.
We use the US, we could have switched to the US enzymes now because they're a fermented enzyme.
And we've had better success with a lower dose.
I know Dr. Gonzalez used to use the poor seed enzymes that had a very high dose.
It's, versus really ill, it's hard for them to take 75 capsules or something a day.
It could be difficult to swallow.
Yeah, yeah.
Then Dr. Connors, do you recommend immune builders to your patients?
Oh, absolutely. That's a key piece because it's your immune system that ultimately has to do the job to kill the cancer.
So you, you know, by changing your diet, you're helping your immune system and you're taking pressure off your immune system.
Because, you know, a poor diet puts a lot of stress on your immune system.
You're firing at a beauty response against antigens, food porn antigens.
So if you could call that whole response down so your immune system could focus on killing the cancer, that's essential.
But you have to, you have to use immune boosting things.
You could call them cancer, killing nutraceuticals, people call them natural chemotherapies.
But it's really just things that are going to help boost that person's immune system to help attack the cancer.
And there's many different ones out there.
And again, we test for what's going to be best for the person so that they're not on too many things.
Then one of your interventions is the rife machine.
And how do you use some patients and how long does it usually take with the rife machine?
So the rife machine is a therapy machine that helps, it's a light frequency generator is what it is.
And with all our cancer patients, we send them home with their own rife machine programmed specifically for them in their cancer.
And they use it at night. You can use it during the day too.
But part of our philosophy is I want a person to go back to living and get their mind off their cancer.
And one of the things that can help that is let's make a big part of your treatment.
Done while you're sleeping, you've got to sleep anyhow.
So we program it for you at night, a little bit different program every night of the week.
And then with their typical daily processes, it's time to go to bed.
They open up the computer, they punch in the program and open it up.
But it's Tuesday and they'll hit Tuesday and they'll hit run and they'll close the computer up.
And let it go to sleep so they can get the EMFs from that.
And they're snuggling with the bulb next to them in bed while they sleep.
And how long do they use it?
Question everybody asks, how long do I have to use this?
We just keep using it forever.
You know, you don't necessarily have to use it every night forever once you feel like you've kind of overcome your cancer.
You always have cancer cells in you, whether you have a diagnosis of cancer or not.
So you want to be conscious of taking care of yourself.
And if you have the right machine, continue to use it at night, takes you 30 seconds, turn it on at night, keep using it.
So we encourage people to continue using it.
How so the RIFE machine then is very important in your protocol since you send the patients home with it?
It is. We've been using the RIFE since the first time I ever saw cancer patient 27 years ago.
And it's partly because that's something I was introduced to when I was in school.
I was intrigued by the RIFE machine.
I don't know why I know why now I believe God put that on my heart.
But you know, I just thought I want to get a RIFE machine so bad.
Actually in my practice, I was practicing chiropractor at the time.
I had the RIFE machine I wanted picked out the picture of it, the brochure up in the wall.
And I had talked to the company several times and just never felt like I had permission to pull the trigger on it.
And one of my patients came in and she was in her late 60s retired.
She came in to me and she goes, I have to talk to you right now.
And I brought her in a back room. She was, I found out I have breast cancer in both breasts.
And they said, she said, they told me if I don't do chemo and radiation, I have three months to live.
And I literally just said, you're telling me this why?
Because you've got to understand I'm not going to do it.
I nursed my friend through the chemo and I'm convinced she died of the chemo.
That was five months ago. I'm not doing chemo.
She said, if you can't help me, I just rather die.
And that was just my, you know, those times like you had a dream to go to the doctor about your lung cancer.
That was time I just felt like you hear the Holy Spirit talk to you and say, it's time to go get it.
I just said, Shar, just come back tomorrow. I'm going to go order a rife machine.
Don't even ask me what it is. I'm going to get it next day, air it to me.
And so that was my start and my journey of trying to help people with this diagnosis.
And she lived another 13 years and actually died of heart attack.
But so we've used the rife with everybody since then.
And so I do think, I really think it's a key component.
Because we've had patients that just refuse to change your diet, refuse to do anything else.
And they did, you know, lived way beyond what they were supposed to.
So I really think it's a key component.
I think it works better if you couple it with diet and nutrition and good supplements and good attitude
and it's a synergistic approach as you know.
Right, right. And I think it's a wonderful story about how you started using it.
I like that. And so you send the patients home with the rife machine.
And do you sell these to other people?
Or do you know reliable sources? Because like you, I've sort of wanted one for a long time.
But I know that there's a lot of them out there that aren't really reliable.
And then there was something I've read called spooky or something or other.
That was being given away free, but I was a little leery of that.
And so I was wondering if you sell them.
Yeah, there's only two braids that I would put my day behind.
Can I mention them on this?
Yeah.
Okay, so the true rife brand, we use that in the GB 4000.
We use that.
So those are the only two that I would really recommend it.
If a person comes to us and they have any other kind and they say, can you use this?
I say no, we need to get one of these two.
The GB 4000 has benefits over the true rife.
And then it has more power.
The true rife has more has benefits over the GB 4000.
And it's much easier to program and get very specific with it.
And it's much more user-friendly.
It's much more durable too.
It's just they just don't break down as much.
So there's benefits to both.
They're both good machines.
They're both good technology.
Do we sell them?
Yes and no.
We do sell programmed rifes for people, but if a person's like, I just want to rife to use for my family.
Then we just tell them to go to the company and buy them.
If they want it specifically programmed for their problem, then yes, we do that.
That's probably the number one reason why people seek us out is our historical use of the rife machine.
So we have patients from literally around the world because of that.
So we've shipped rifes into many other countries.
To try to help people with typically with cancer or live disease.
The rife is a great tool to help your cells, health of your cells, the health of living things,
to help kill viruses or bacteria or funguses to help kill cancer.
It's not the tool, let's say if I have made a problem as mercury toxicity.
I would pick chelation therapy or something.
The rife is not really the tool for that, but it's a tool that has to be used properly.
It's not a magic wand.
A lot of people on Facebook are interested in that and the rife machine.
And also there is a group that I was invited to join.
And so I recently joined it.
And that's all they do is talk about the rife machine.
I don't have a lot of free time to get there to check out very much.
But it's something I've been interested in for a long time.
It's the same as the beamer and we'll get to that with the PEMF shortly.
But the beamer was something I had wanted for a long time.
Then I broke down two years ago and got the beamer and I used it.
So that was helpful.
Then you use other interventions like the hyperbaric oxygen therapy, the hypothermia,
the PEMF therapy light beam generator, SEQEX therapy and others.
And I wasn't familiar with the light beam and the SEQEX therapy.
So the SEQEX is equivalent to the beamer.
It's a low frequency PEMF.
That's very similar to the beamer.
The only advantage that the SEQEX has over the beamer is that you can program it specifically for specific frequencies.
That's the only advantage.
But otherwise it's almost identical as far as the ghost output of the beamer.
The light beam generator is another form of rife.
But it's set frequencies that you can't program.
So it's only set on human body frequency.
So that would be more beneficial for lymphatic detoxification.
So help get lymph moving.
That's what the light beam generator would be good for.
If somebody was said, oh I have cancer, I'm taking a bite of light beam generator, should I?
I'd spend a pick that would not be my first pick.
But it has benefits to it.
The PEMF that we use is a pulse brand, which is a high frequency PEMF, high impulse PEMF.
It's very strong.
It has advantages over the beamer and SEQEX for certain things.
This really different tool, so you could use them a little bit differently.
I know what you're trying to achieve.
I know Dr. Vickers at the Gerson clinic in Mexico uses the beamer.
The beamer, like the SEQEX, I think the advantage of that, the PEMF isn't going to kill cancer cells.
It helps rejuvenate your whole cells, helps open up your cell membranes, it helps detoxification.
What are the biggest benefits of the PEMF?
It helps cell membrane charge back.
That's something you can measure with different instrumentation to see what your cell charge is at.
You see people that are more ill, have a much lower cell charge.
PEMF is really essential and helps boosting that, helping cell membrane health.
You mentioned detoxing, which is another important aspect.
Can you tell us then about your detoxing apart of the protocol?
Whatever you make any lifestyle, I mean, detoxing is something your body is doing constantly or you'll be dead.
Your liver is what the main purpose of your liver is helping clean out poisons from your kidneys as well.
It's those pathways that can become overwhelmed that then decrease by rate of detoxification.
I always say that your toxic load is really your level of toxic burden.
How many toxins you're exposed to, either breathing, eating them or putting them on your skin,
minus how your level of detoxification, your rate of detoxification.
If your rate of detoxification is not exceeding your toxic load,
then you're going to have a toxic burden. These toxins are going to settle somewhere.
They won't stay in your blood or you'll be poisoned, so they'll be pushed to your extracellular spaces or within the cells themselves.
That's where they can cause problems.
You want to support the detoxification pathway starting at the end point.
In your liver, you have phase 1, phase 2, phase 2.5, and phase 3 of how you get rid of poisons.
You want to support all those phases.
To get more specific, when you look at a person's genetics, you want to support the pathways that you have defects on.
Let's say, for instance, the cytochrome P450 pathway or the P1 pathway or the NAT pathway.
I have a lot of defects in my P1 pathway.
I want to use specific nutrition that has some research data that will support the P1 pathway or if I pull stuff out of my cells,
it circulates back into my bloodstream and I can get it out of my liver.
Well, I could make myself more sick than I was before, so you want to start at the drain point, you could say.
The drain point could even be further down. Of course, it's constipated.
They're going to be reabsorbing those toxins, so you've got to make sure their bowel habits are up to stuff using coffee.
If you have to, to help delivered, help with constipation issues, supporting those specific genetic pathways, supporting phase 1, 2, 2.5 and 3,
and then start helping support cellular detoxification.
And that's where the rif could come in. That's where the beaver type machines could come in to help with cellular detoxification as well.
Do you advocate the sauna at all?
Oh, absolutely, because the sauna helps some bypass the liver and kidney basically because you're using the skin as your portal of detoxification.
So, we really push people to sauna if they can.
It just takes one more pressure off of your liver, for sure.
You mentioned earlier about different ways that you diagnose, and you mentioned it almost was like an approach of guidance that you receive.
And I love that you include the spiritual aspects because I believe that the holistic approach is the approach that will prevent recurrences.
Can you tell us about this aspect of care that you incorporate the spiritual aspect?
Well, regardless of a person's faith that we're going to purposely try to proselytize anybody to our like Christian belief, but you have to have a level of desire to get better.
And you have to also, I just think with any disease process, okay, so I have a diagnosis of cancer, you have to be introspective enough to go, oh, is it something in my psyche that was at least a part of this part of the cause?
Was it repressed thoughts or suppressed past trauma?
Is it current emotional stress that I'm dealing with?
You have to ask those tough questions of yourself and be introspective enough to be honest with yourself, to get into a healthier place.
And from our Christian belief, I believe you need to ask God those things.
Ask the Holy Spirit to reveal to you, you know, like the Bible says, Lord, if there be any wicked way in me, please tell me, show me, because sometimes our flesh could easily cover it up in a lot of ways.
So we need guidance to have that be uncovered.
And that's the benefit of honest friends and multitude of counselors around you that could maybe reveal things in you that you don't see yourself.
So be introspective, I think, is important.
But also, on that same side, be careful not to be too introspective.
We can easily go into the blame game where we blame ourselves and kind of beat ourselves up as well.
And that, you know, depending on your personality type, that could be the problem right there, too.
So the other big thing that we try to share with our patients is most people when they get a serious diagnosis, they go through different phases of grief, you could say.
And I really believe doing this for as many years as we've done this with as many patients as we've had.
The ones that could get to the point of, well, this is a blessing too.
And that prays God for my cancer because if it wasn't for my cancer, I wouldn't look at life the way I'm looking at it right now.
I wouldn't value every sunrise.
I wouldn't enjoy my grandkids the way I'm enjoying them right now.
I wouldn't odd and odd and odd like that.
I think at least historically in my practice, the people that get to the point where they're not mad at the cancer anymore,
angry at, you know, you see these bumper stickers that say, cancer, socks, or worse than that, language.
I know you have to kind of go through that, maybe.
But I think you have to come out the other side of that and go, there was a purpose in this too.
And I can see the good in this as well.
And those are the people that we've seen do the best.
And have the best quality of life through their cancer as well.
If you're just going to be angry and bitter because you have cancer and die in that state, I think that was good for anybody.
So I think that's important.
So we try to encourage people.
Everybody's got to walk through that, but we really try to encourage people through that.
I know exactly what you're talking about because I went through the same process
and came out the other side much more positive, much more optimistic, grateful, et cetera, et cetera.
And that's partly where I got interested in the holistic approach.
But prior to that, I had worked with the Edgar Casey readings and friends with the Casey family and used to volunteer as the nurse for camp
because I was teaching at the university and I was off summer so I go to the camp.
And I got to know a lot of the Casey readings, but the research now, again, is showing so much like being positive, being optimistic.
There's a big thing on gratitude.
There's a big thing on forgiveness.
And one thing that I found when I was researching my last book was that some of the research shows the effect of the attitude and forgiveness on the body
because the research now shows that it causes chronic anxiety and leads to a depletion to the killer cells.
So you're less able to fight and 60% of all cancer patients have a problem with forgiveness.
Another one is optimism that affects, I think if I remember right, it's the CA 125 protein that is one of the markers for ovarian cancer.
It affects that.
And colon cancer as well.
And so the research is beginning to come out showing how you know the spiritual, what I call spiritual, I think all of these are spiritual.
I don't think it's religious.
I think it's non-denominational, but it's a spiritual aspect of care that has been ignored for so long.
And so I was excited when I saw that you were involved in including that as part of your protocol.
Yeah, I think it's essential.
Then can you tell us about are you inpatient outpatient?
What is the process to the patient come and stay a few days and then take things home and work and come back?
Yeah, we have a couple different programs.
Most of our patients will come here to Minnesota for two days and some people will spend a week, some people will spend longer.
We have some variable options.
We treat everybody individualistic in that way, but most people will be here for what we call a two day intensive where we can get most of our testing done.
They want to stay longer for the therapies that we have that they maybe can't get into their area.
Lots of times when people come from out of the country, they'll stay much longer.
And then they go home with a rife.
That's what makes us really different than most other clinics is they're going to home with the main tools.
I don't think you can be cured in three weeks at a center.
I think it's mostly what you do at home.
So you go home with the most important thing the rife I think.
And we also have a program, some people just can't travel or they hate to travel.
We actually have staff that will come to your house.
So nearly every week one of my lead practitioners is off to San Diego or to Santa Barbara or wherever.
And spending two to three days in that person's house doing most everything that we do in the office.
They bring machinery with them.
And that's spent a really blessing to a lot of people too.
And then they again leave the rife machine and they still do most of the testing and such.
So we have people that choose that that's a little bit more expensive because the cost of us will come in there.
It's whatever works. Sometimes it's better to get out of your environment to become someplace else to get a fresh start.
Sometimes it's hard for people to travel and they're too ill to travel too.
And do you include the family in some of this?
Oh you have to.
Oh good.
So that's absolutely essential because you need that support system.
Sadly you talk about the spiritual side.
Sometimes it's the lack of that support system or the lack of support of their support system that could often be a piece of the cause of the person's illness.
So sometimes our role morphs in to try to help counsel family and how to be the best support for the patient.
But the family has to be a part of that caregiving process.
I think it's healthy for them as well to learn how to best help somebody else.
There could be a healing process to that too.
That's wonderful.
I know I took a group of students to the University of West of England in Bristol.
This was back in the 90s and we went to a cancer center where they brought the families there for a week.
I think it was.
And oriented the families to everything that they were providing with the patient.
And that was the first time I had seen that in operation.
And I thought it was a wonderful idea.
Yes.
Then is there anything else you'd like to say before we look at any services products, books, your website and so forth?
It was just that we try to have, you know, I feel like what we do is a ministry.
We have to charge for our service because I have staff to pay and bills to pay.
But our information we try to give as much away as possible we offer.
I offer my book because of free download.
I offer, you know, we have probably 400 videos on YouTube.
We have 300 plus, maybe 400 blog pages with valuable information.
We have created lots of with videos on hundreds of pages of website and other books on live and autoimmune disease as well that are mostly free downloads as well.
So we try to encourage people.
We get people many times will call us that they're living on 700 dollars a month.
Social security, they don't have money for anything.
We just try to at least get on our newsletter list.
It'll give you a bunch of self help.
Download our book for self help things you could do.
There's so much you could do, but just change your outlook and attitude and perspective of life and dealing with any serious disease.
Well, yeah, if you can also tell us your website.
Sure, it's Conner's Clidic.
C-O-N-N-E-R-S.
Clidic.
Conner'sClidic.com.
Or you go to Conner's Clidic.
Slash Books.
Or you could download our book for free.
But on our website, you'll see the links to the books.
You'll see just a bunch of information on everything that we spoke about today.
I'd like to make videos because if I had another life to live, I'd be a teacher.
I'd like to teach.
I feel like I go to a seminar and I learn something.
I think, well, how can I teach other people that?
They can be helped by this too.
We try to, anything I learn to pass it on, I just feel like that's my role and my obligation.
Stay tuned with us and keep up with our newsletters to learn as much as you possibly can.
It's like with your podcast like this is fantastic for people.
And that's a wonderful role to play Dr. Conner's.
I admire that very much.
And I appreciate so much you taking the time to talk with me because it's good to know what's going on out in the real world.
The listeners are very interested in this.
Some of them, I get a lot of people that come to the podcast from other countries where they don't have quite the advantages that we do.
And so they try to make do with what they have.
So I appreciate this very much and I hope to talk with you again in the future and see what updates you have.
Oh, thank you, Dr. Conner.
Appreciate all you do and how much you've spent a whole lifetime helping people.
Thank you.